[Music]
just like that we're thick in the middle
of the season guys things just went by
so quickly didn't they they've been
getting heated and i'm enjoying this
season's anime demon slayer and attack
on titan have been as good as they've
always been and i'm so glad they're
doing a decent job on arie fiureta for
the second season oh and princess
connect second season comes with a lot
of revelations that i being a player of
the mobile game got absolutely mind
blown by but today isn't about those big
hits that have left their legacies for
us to enjoy today what i'll be doing is
giving a mid-season talk of sorts about
some of my favorite new anime so strap
yourselves in and let's look at what i
think are the best new anime so far
we start off the list with love of kill
[Music]
well here's a show we overlooked a bit
in the seasonal preview hey there are so
many good and promising shows for a top
10. anyway love of kill is one
interesting show it revolves around
bounty hunter chateau and her encounter
with asian assassins son in a twist of
fate son also happens to be hunting her
down and the two come into a compromise
in exchange for going out with him son
will help her out behind the scenes now
things get a little bit more complicated
when the two are made to face their dark
past that come knocking with no one they
can trust the two may be forced to rely
on each other to get through it now this
show caught me by surprise the dynamic
between cold sunday female and the
opposite is a tried and true formula but
it never gets old i also found the level
of violence and the way the character
dynamics are in the series interesting
but i guess that's to be expected
because it is a jose series a
demographic that we don't see in anime
that often if you're up for a romance
that's dark and mature this could be
something worth picking up
[Music]
up next we have tokyo 24th ward
now this was one of the shows that i
took an interest in entering the season
tokyo 24th ward is a new original anime
by cloverworks and it promised
superpowers drama and mysteries you've
got an interesting premise with three
estranged friends forced to work
together to protect the future of their
home the whole dead friend mystery and
superpowers it even began with a double
episode special that sets the tone of
the series really well then the pacing
slows down and we get quite a lot of
setup before jumping back into the fray
with the action i find the show nice
enough but i can also see why some
people feel tuned out by it clover works
well still being one of the studios i
really like surely hasn't endeared
themselves recently with the
controversies related to promise
neverland 2 and wonder egg priority now
this looks to be headed towards that
direction as well but i am holding out
hope that this will end up being one of
the home runs that they put out this
season after all they've already got a
show that i'm very high on later on this
list
we then move on to genius prince's guide
to raising a nation out of debt
yay more kingdom building anime now this
isn't to be confused with realist hero
no matter how similar the aesthetics may
be genius prince is about the titular
prince who's an actual genius and one of
the best rulers the kingdom of natara
can hope to have unfortunately for the
constituents there's nothing that the
genius prince wants more than to sell
the place off to the highest bidder and
get rid of it even more unfortunately
for him though things seem to conspire
against him and setting off the kingdom
just gets harder and harder at least
with each failure he starts seeing the
kingdom and the citizens for what they
are this is an anime that hits a home
run with its comedic time in a
surprisingly good character and world
building it seems simple at first glance
but it's anything but that when you
start getting into it i would definitely
recommend it
now here's a show us older folks can
relate to you get the best of both
worlds business and salary man life as
well as the repercussions of super high
stakes bad winter matches grounded in
reality of course well the tale goes
that mikoto shiratori gets fired from
his company after losing a badminton
match and as luck would have it he
wouldn't be either for long as he gets
recruited by another company pretty soon
after that the thing is mikoto is not
exactly fond of doubles matches and he's
roped into being partners with tatsuru
could the pair overcome teeth clenched
teamwork and rise to the top another
show that i don't blame anyone for
overlooking sarri man's club takes a
fresh spin on the usual sports anime
we've gotten used to seeing so far it's
given us strong episodes that i've
enjoyed but i'm sure that we're in for
some drama to drive the stakes even
higher eventually
before we move on to our next entry ever
had a situation where you wanted to
watch the titles i recommend but you
find yourself unable to do it legally
well that sounds like a job for
everyone's best friend on the go and the
sponsors of this video expressvpn ever
wanted to bypass region locks and watch
more anime ever wanted to access
facebook or reddit in places where
they're blocked you know who to call if
you're still not convinced then hear me
out wanna watch your name on netflix
just go to expressvpn and click on the
australian server and boom now you can
enjoy your name and dozens of other
anime movies just like that you can try
it yourself and it is as easy as it
looks the only thing separating you from
watching the next episode of your
favorite anime in a foreign country is
the click of a button in addition to
bypassing region locks expressvpn also
provides outstanding protection from the
dangers of the internet expressvpn is
here to act as your unbeatable shield
against those cyber attacks to get your
super cheap expressvpn subscription just
follow the link in the description box
or type in
expressvpn.comtube to get started
life with an ordinary guy who
reincarnated into a total knockout
fantasy is up next
wow
that's quite a mouthful for the title
yeah and it's another new take on isakai
after all where else would we find in
isaika where the protagonist and his
best friend get summoned to another
world with the clause that our hero ends
up being a complete bombshell of a girl
that's
said handsome friend tsukasa now must
defeat the demon lord not just to save
the world but also to get him back to
his original body the premise should
clue you in already it's one of those
weird japanese things at first glance
but it ended up being a winner it's got
great comedy owing to the setting and
those expecting a generic isakai will
find themselves getting more than what
they expected it's a rom-com isakai that
derives its humor from how ridiculous
some of the situations are and it is a
load of fun
we continue with the orbital
here's a netflix show for you it tells
of a group of children set up to have
some fun times in space however life has
other plans for them and their adventure
gets crashed by an accident left with
each other and technology they have to
work together in order to overcome the
dangers that await them in space
mysteries abound and we're given a story
that sets us up to root for a rag tag
group of children but i think that it's
the art that's most noteworthy given the
nature of the production that's also to
be expected and it helps emphasize how
we perceive its world the show is quite
immersive as a result on a surface level
but it also contains a lot of themes
that can be uncovered once we dig a bit
further past the surface we're talking
about meta commentaries on influencer
culture ethics and the like the pacing
of orbital children can be a little bit
hit or miss but it's overall a
beautifully drawn series that has some
relevant themes that people might enjoy
and relate to
next up is arkeby's sailor uniform
comfy slice of life anime with cute
girls is a genre that doesn't go out of
flavor of course most of these come with
an eye-catching premise to at least get
a bit of attention and in this case it's
our protagonist loving sailor uniforms
only to find out that they've been
phased out in her school still intent on
honoring her mum's superb sewing argebi
decides to keep using the uniform in
school putting her in an odd girl out
situation as she starts meeting new
friends and experiencing the wonders of
school life with them above anything i
give prompts to this show for its superb
attention to detail with a visual
presentation you can clearly see how
much care has been put into creating the
show and animating what was just
supposed to be cute girls doing cute
things the interactions come off as
heartwarming and wholesome and it's a
show like this that we need in these
trying times we can clearly see which
show cloverworks put more effort in in
terms of the animation and while it's
got some fan service going the show's
all cute fun and warm
[Music]
i've had great hopes for rust itabisco
coming into the season and those
expectations have been met when i saw
this show i expected an outrageous
action-filled adventure and it held up
to its end of the bargain big time the
fights are cool and all but it's the
world building where this show shines
the most giving us a nice few episodes
to kick off the series and set us into a
world that's way different from our own
yep you heard that right we're here for
some wild over the top fun and over the
top front is what we get in this ride
through a post-apocalyptic world it's
buoyed by the engaging and compelling
characters and as far as production
values go i've got no complaints
whatsoever about this show for studio
wise's first project the guys have come
up with a winner granted i've not read
the source material much but as an anime
only watcher i'm thoroughly enjoying the
ride and that my friends is always a
good sign
last but not least we have my dress-up
darling
waifu of the season confirmed this for
me is one of the more unexpected shows
to blow up but on the other hand was it
that surprising given how much of a
charismatic beauty marin is she really
pushes this show about cosplay to newer
heights in terms of popularity but
saying that people are watching the show
just for marrying is wrong in my opinion
after all the show also relies on the
strength of the lead gojo a very nice
lead a serious and straight-laced guy
who serves as the perfect foil for our
outgoing girl their interactions are fun
to watch and had such a great time
seeing him get pulled by marin's whims
it's got a lot of fan service however so
this is likely not something i'd
recommend to those not to tune to anime
culture still if you're up for a show
that's wholesome and romantic underneath
all the sexy then this could be your
show of the season
[Music]
now we've come to the end of the list
it's been a joy to write and it's also
fun to see how many of these great shows
went under the radar during my preseason
video i'd like to know your favorite
amongst these new anime so head to the
comment section and make sure you chime
in if you're interested in connecting
directly you can also hop onto the
discord channel for vini tube as well as
check out my instagram and patreon
that's it for this video stay safe stay
strong and thank you for watching
[Music]
you